good morning believe nation if you're
worried that you're not thinking big
enough that you're not acting big enough
that you're not doing enough that I'm
going to share an inspiring clip from 50
cent that I think will help I'm a rapper
entrepreneur a person that has doesn't
see limitations I have my person who has
high expectations for myself and when I
actually start to look at some of the
things that I've accomplished and I
become a little more interested in my
legacy like what people remember me as
is what made it more important that I
involved myself in philanthropy because
the people they resonate the strongest
in their absence have done more for for
people when they were actually in anger
positions this is a great clip and one
that really resonates with me because
I'm constantly questioning myself I'm
thinking am i doing enough am I thinking
big enough am I do I have limiting
beliefs that are holding me where I am
are my expectations for myself high
enough can I raise that bar and how do I
do it and I think a great way to think
about that is what's my legacy gonna be
you want to think about how are your
kids gonna remember you and your
grandkids gonna remember you what's
going to be written in the newspapers
the day you die right what's that
lasting memory that lasting impact that
you want to have on the world after
you're gone and at least for me it makes
me think like I got to do more I got to
raise the expectations I have on myself
because I want my legacy to be something
great and in order for that to happen I
got to raise the bar increase the
standards that I put on myself increase
my own expectations think bigger because
I want to have that positive legacy so
the question of the day for you today is
what's the legacy you want to leave I'm
really curious leave it in the comments
below
what's that lasting mark that you're
gonna put on this world and how are you
going to go out and start achieving that
today thank you so much for watching if
you liked the video and you want to see
more don't forget to leave a
subscribe to the channel subscribe to
the newsletter and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
entrepreneurship to kick start your day
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon